ladies and gentlemen this video has been
such a long time coming let me say you
got a friend
if you've got a family member if you
yourself
have ever seen one of these ads these
walmart automation or amazon
automation ads and you're thinking of
getting involved
this is the video you need to watch if
you've ever wondered man
is it really true that i can just make
100k a year with an amazon store is it
that easy
this is the video for you so i had to
get the suit on because honestly i
wanted to be authoritative
it's teaching time boys this is my new
this is the sifu suit
in the 10 million dollar studio guys
with the lambo in the back that's how
you know i'm trustworthy guys is the
fake lambo in the back
honestly this video is very unprompted
normally i have my topics that i'm going
to cover
and this one's off course it's off topic
it's off track
why because one guy really pissed me off
dude
now let's go to the board so i can show
you more okay
what got me all in a huff right uh well
it's guys like this
okay now these aren't the guys this is
just the setup okay for the record
okay hey what's going on my name is
logan i am with the man the myth the
legend right
this guy you've never seen before in
your life mr cgi
face anyway what whatever what's his
name what's his name here this is the
e-commerce
wizard he's been doing oh-ho he's the
wizard dude
e-com wizard bro e-commerce automation
for a minute helping
hundreds of clients make money online
manny why don't you just take a second
and explain why
e-commerce automation makes sense in
this day and age it makes so much sense
right now because where else can you
make
you know 15 a month on your money 15
a month on your money guys that's just
the start
of the bold bold claims that these guys
make
now i feel like this whole industry of
uh people should be called
douche bags in front of expensive cars
selling scams because you know these
guys are honestly a dime a dozen
you see this guy here he's another guy
and he's actually the guy that really
pissed me off he's the reason i'm making
this whole video he's here selling a
little amazon automation store as well
what's up guys nolan johnson here you've
probably seen my ads talking about drop
shipping
and why it's not a good business the
reason why is because a lot of people
don't know what they're doing so what we
do is we actually set up a fully
automated amazon store in your name
and we handle everything from a to z
it's a hundred percent automated
a hundred percent automated guys just
like that and you know what he just
started a second branch too
where he's selling a walmart automated
stores he's charging fifty thousand
dollars up front and saying
that you can make 100k a year in profit
that's what he's projecting
uh now that's ridiculous and i'll
explain why in a second but he says
how to have a completely automated
walmart store to make you daily profit
and then up here he violates a walmart's
trademark right there
and uses their slogan to i guess try to
affiliate himself with
walmart like make money live better
isn't that that
walmart slogan save money live better
walmart uh but then he go ahead he has
these right here which is like as seen
on and it's
every single news outlet in existence it
seems like
uh which this is a graphic pool and it's
it's on a bunch of other websites as
well
um i found it on mattclarkagency.com
i'm at selfstorageinvesting.com with a
simple reverse image search so uh that's
it's not even his image he just like
pasted this graphic to try to seem
authoritative
but then you know you go up here he says
100k a year in profit
literally in the tiny fine print he says
we cannot guarantee sales
income or profit your results may vary
well
vary by how much you're putting 50k down
and then guess what
that's not even the end of the story
then you got to pay for inventory you
got to pay for everything and
then if you're lucky enough to make a
profit you get 70
of it and they're saying oh we're going
to make we're going to make 100k a year
what if you don't well uh you have all
the risk
that's the beauty of amazon automation
and walmart automation
is no matter what the guy the guru the
guy standing in front of the rich
the rich car they make 50k right away
if you open a store no questions asked
look they don't do anything
and they've made fifty thousand dollars
maybe they run your store a little bit
they pass it off to a few uh
workers of vietnam a few va's virtual
assistants in vietnam this is how the
business model works
maybe they make a few sales to tell you
hey go shut up for a little while but
maybe they don't
and what happens what happens if they
don't what's your exposure to risk
well you have all of the risk they put
up no money for your store
and they say they they make excuses that
the reason they make these stores the
reason they need to invest with you
is because oh i can't open more than one
store on amazon you ever heard this
before i can't open more than one store
in walmart that's why i have to partner
with you that's not true
it's not even true yes they can why
wouldn't they do this look if they're so
confident they're gonna make all this
money
why wouldn't they take their own money
invest it and just have put it under
someone else's name and pay them like
five percent
to be the uh you know non-working
managing director
or ten percent i'll tell you why because
in that case they take the risk no no
they don't want to take the risk these
people have figured out that a lot of
people are dumb enough to take
all of the risk and only have a small
amount of upside what's worse
is they encourage you to go into debt
they tell you that uh you should take
out a personal loan
for the cost of the of the store okay
that's that's a gem
next question what if i don't have that
much money what if you're
a sucker who doesn't have any money
you're not a qualified buyer what do you
do you take out a personal loan right
credit scores are in the 700s and you
have good income with a good debt to
income ratio
lendingtree or sofi will give you a
personal loan
all you have to do is visit their
website and then come back
and apply do uh work with us that's
right guys
use a personal loan for a business high
interest rates that's great dude this
guy's encouraging this
look at this guy not only does he
encourage personal loans check out what
else he encourages
let's say you have 20 000 available
on your credit card ooh 20k on your
credit card to fund those orders yeah
you forgot that you're also finding all
the order forms
go ahead charge up the rack up that
credit card to fund these orders
we can help you make roughly ten
thousand dollars a month in profit
if we max your card out every single
month guys
just just max your credit card out every
single month
do it for the amazon automated store
guys
again do you notice do you notice you
take all the risk
and they take nothing and then watch how
he tries to compare
subway where you get a store like a
physical store
and a known brand to drop shipping
and tries to say oh look how cheap the
franchise fee is
we only charge 50 000 that's one-fifth
the price of your average subway
what you can't even compare the two what
one you're getting a store the second
one you're getting nothing what are you
getting
walmart seller third-party seller
account that you could have opened for
free
these people literally have no there's
there's there's no morality here guys
there's no
there's no thought of like wait what's
gonna happen to these people if they
they lose their money they lose their
50k investment
now at this point you might go to their
refund policy and try to you know feel
better because they say
that if they don't profit enough within
the first 12 months
to cover the upfront investment they
will refund you wow
that's very nice of them until you
figure out it's void
in the event of and they have a bunch of
really common things
like hey if you if you don't have the
exact amount of capital at the time
you've already maxed out all your credit
cards
hey lack of necessary capital that
restricts store growth
and which is any time that they can't
fund the order right away hey
lack no refund void you get your voided
refund but you know what else is crazy
any potential refund is void in the
event of any suspension
of the client store guys do you know how
common it is
for amazon stores to get suspended for
example i know we're talking about
walmart right now
but you know how common it is for amazon
stores to get suspended we haven't seen
that many walmart
uh suspensions yet and i'm sure those
are coming though as all of these shady
guys get involved in the business
it's all the time and the key is that
that happens
not when because you're not touching the
store not when you do something wrong
they do something wrong and then the
refund's gone
so they screw up it's written it's
literally written in the contract
that if they mess up your store you get
screwed
out of your 50k you literally can't make
this stuff up how mind-blowing
is that and these these terms and
conditions are common dude they're
common
across the industry now finally i want
to use some math to break down why these
guys
are scumbag liars and i say these guys
uh very loosely and i also say
scumbag liars as an opinion guys you
know so i've got an alternative plan
for you that you could ask any amazon
automation store guy or any walmart
automation store guy
to help you or sorry to help them and
they'll never take you up on this deal
even though theoretically if their
numbers were right
they'd make more money with my plan okay
so you ready go to your amazon or
walmart automation guy
and when they say hey front me the money
uh because basically i
i need to create more stores but i can't
because of these suspensions that's what
they say right that's their explanation
for why they need
your money they say i can't create more
than one third-party store
instead tell them this tell them hey
i'll put my name on that store
if you just give me 10 of the profits
not 70
like they're talking about they always
talk about the 70 30 split right they're
going to give you 70
they're going to get 30 say no you you
the amazon automation guy you get 90
i'll get 10 but i don't put up any money
so i'm just putting my name on the
business
i'm letting you open up as you know
another third party store uh you just
give me 10 000.
so let's run their numbers let's say you
know your store makes a hundred thousand
dollars
in the first year like they say it's
going to they're gonna say it's a
hundred thousand dollars
in profit if they have it their way year
one
they make with eighty thousand dollars
hope everyone's clear on how i got to
that number
my way where they get ninety percent of
the profits they'd make more money
in the first year you see that why would
they do this if they're confident they
could make a hundred thousand dollars a
year
why would they do this were they only
taking 30 of the profits it's worse for
them well
wait let's let's repeat that if they
could really make those numbers
why would they choose to make less money
when they're the
ones putting in all the work they even
say you don't even have to put any work
so what am i getting at here they know
that with my plan where they just pay
somebody to take you know
to build a store but they they put in
all the risk they know that they're
taking the risk and they don't
they're not confident they can do the
stores they can't get the actual profits
they say they can't
they know that so what do they do they
rig it so no matter what they
make 50k they make the initial
storefront fee
and they run they know they don't need
you anymore
they have the money it's no risk on them
what are you going to do if you don't
like it you're going to sue them oh
they'll fight you with your own
money that's the problem with these
scammers what you're going to sue the
guy who charged you 50 000
he'll fight you with his 50 000 good
luck and maybe he'll settle out of court
you know later like how
where are you getting your money back
guys so i want you to think more
intelligently about this stuff these
people are absolute
scumbags because you got to ask yourself
do the math
why would they if they could actually do
what they say
why wouldn't they just take the money
why would they give you such a high cut
in all of these automation things they
always give you like 70
of the profits why would they do that if
you're doing no work if they could
really do it
it is literally a confidence game it's a
confidence
scam i know most of you guys this is
obvious
right it's obvious to most people that
you know these guys can't really do it
they're fly-by-night salesman
they literally they literally are
encouraging you to go into personal debt
and maxing out your credit card every
month okay
and yeah that's basically it send this
to your friends family loved ones
brothers sister mothers
uh if they're getting involved in a scam
because i know they are listen my mom
got in a scam the other day
i'm just going to be honest he'd be
straightforward with you she got in a
ponzi scheme mlm
i'm sorry it happens to everyone even
sifu's mom just is what it is uh so yeah
that's it basically thanks for watching
i'll see you next time i know what you
need
this ain't what it seems nothing but a
trick trying to sell me on a dream but
that was where you lost
wake up smell the me
[Music]